hello everyone
scp049 here
today i am going to be playing a game
called
plague inc a game where you can design
a plague on the fly
today my plague will be called the cure
what else will be called
i'm going to start my plague in
madagascar
for one simple reason
in this game you are developing a plague
before it is introduced to the general
populace
it's better to be very infectious now if
you
isolate where your plague
originates so an island like
madagascar is a very small isolated
island so
it can grow to be very strong and potent
without raising any suspicion
and the cure to my cure
will never be developed in time
so because i have the dna points i'm
going to buy
air transmission
whenever i have enough points next i
think
the best course of action would be water
because air and water are the main
ways that a plague can spread throughout
the world
i know this first hand i have dealt with
a lot of
them the infection at this point
on land is quite slow
and i have to remember to click every
single thing that pops up on the map
as it gives me disease points
to spend on evolving my plague
for the sake of this i will refer to
my plague act simply as
my plague as calling it the cure
will be slightly confusing
as there is such a thing as a cure
in this game of course not the type of
cure
that i condone as
i am very specific vision
in mind for the cure as you all well
know
so currently
my plague has left madagascar
and has spread to neighboring areas now
these neighboring areas all have one
thing in common
they are all extremely hot
they have a high temperature and
whenever i get my disease points
up i will be buying heat
resistance which aids the disease in
spreading in
hot climates
so
insects are very popular in these
climates as well
i will devolve every single symptom that
my plague
naturally evolves at this stage for a
couple of reasons
you get disease points back and
the less life-threatening your diseases
the less popular you are amongst
scientists trying to counteract your
playing
i might i don't want scientists to find
it
until of course they are afflicted in a
very serious way and
die because
the disease is very strong in every
single one of them
so
i'm trying to figure out what the best
course of action is right now
i don't think farm and livestock is the
best
i don't think so no
of course america and all first world
countries are always the hardest
to infect so eventually i will need to
invest in some
extra help
and that comes in the form of
improved resistance to medicine
there's a lot of bias it's popping up
that's a good sign
good sign okay
deary me that's a very good sign
so this will increase my effectiveness
in cold and in first world countries
in my experience the uk and america are
always the last
to go
also greenland seems to be
one of those countries that is quite
hard to affect
as stated earlier it does have a similar
makeup to madagascar it is quite removed
from the rest of the world as it only
has one port
so
more biohazard signs
infection still is spreading quite
slowly i'm going to have to invest in
more
transmission types
rats pigeons well
the same infectivity but
for two less disease points
i'm going to have to nip that symptom in
the blood
thank you very much i will take those
deceased points
infections still spreading very slowly
this does not please me
but then again a lot more biohazard
signs
popping up
for anyone curious as to how quickly
this is spreading
if you look in the top right hand corner
i have flash forward forwarded to run at
three times normal speed
because there is a lot of waiting in
this game
for the plague simply to run its course
so i think i'm going to
much more this is
quite
i'll probably leave that for later lots
of bio as it's good
good good china seems to be picking up
that's good
oh the infection is spreading rather
nicely now
of course the reason it is spreading so
rapidly is that
china is so densely populated
and because i have birds and rats as
transmission
very heavily featured in urban areas
it does speed up the infection this is
great to see
fast
curious to see there are 16
760 people dead and it doesn't even have
any extra
symptoms very strange
very strange
106 disease points seven
good whenever i reach
100 of the world infected i like to have
at least 100 because then i can
kick the symptoms into overdrive
i like to aim for total system failure
in my experience dealing with
infected individuals
total organ failure never ends well you
can never really come back from that
especially when i am involved
so let's see
i think i will do this because america
isn't infected at all
whereas the uk seems to be
if not entirely
pretty much gone good
good usa very slow
very slowly progressing in the grand
scheme of things
picking up a little bit now good
i can hear girls singing in the
background in this game audio
very disconcerting now russia as well
that seems to be coming on very nicely
usa is pretty much gone
this is good this is what we like to see
nice huge red chunks on the map
as i've stated before greenland seems to
be
the last one to go every single time
very curious very curious
i think i may need to invest in some
more
temperature resistance just to kick
start it slightly
at this point in the game there isn't
very much more biohazards
left to occur really canada's coming on
nicely there
greenland
very slow very slow
this is a pickle
usa was infected within
two minutes whereas greenland just seems
to be
extremely resilient
so bacterial resistance full temperature
in all climates this should be fine
speeding up slightly slowly but surely
patience is the key
i really don't want to go below 100
as i've said before i really want to
kick this into overdrive as soon as
they're all infected
and to evolve that to get
i did it i think i lost dna points there
oh well that
is unfortunate
i am unsure as to how that happened
very strange anyway back to greenland
seems to be faring very badly that's
always a good thing
in my book they are the last country i
need to conquer
before i start to inject symptoms
into my cure my plague
it's all very confusing
needless to say they will all
be cured eventually
as the infection is spreading very
nicely ingrained
that temperature resistance really did
pay off
marvelous
goodbye greenland you are mine now
and done
no healthy people left on the planet
so as i've said throughout
i'm going to aim for total
organ failure which is always here
i have spare dna points
yeah why not powerless good
good stuff now
i will be getting a lot of news reports
telling me how well my disease is
killing people now
as you can see at the bottom bar is
gradually turning black
[Music]
i have to stomp the cure out of the
stage
as it is progressing quite fast
alarmingly fast
possibly a little faster than i might
want it
to be if you can pair the bars in growth
stop that out but i am getting disease
points because i am killing so many
people
so if it reaches the stage where it is
getting
unmanageable and is about to overtake me
i can [ __ ] the growth of the cure
i'm sorry i usually don't raise my voice
but this is quite exciting
so 80 dna points i think i will buy some
genetic hardening
let's see what that did
well the cure has slowed down
and i am speeding up
stopping that cure out as
things progress
genetic reshuffle should yes
good
now it should be momentary
it seems to be slowing down as it
reaches 100
this is very confusing
perhaps the scientists are developing a
cure
and they're not telling me about it that
is quite
alarming
close to extinction not business as
usual anymore
are we people no
i might as well just spend these on more
symptoms
to try and get rid of the last of
humanity
the last survivors
and another symptom has mutated so
that's
very good very good indeed
okay
why is it so slow to destroy humanity
that's good
good it's a good sign
the cure seems to have completely halted
because i think i
have killed all the scientists
and indeed the world
i hope this has been an informative
guide
to destroying humanity
thank you for watching this playthrough
of plague
inc i look forward to seeing you all
next time
and as always i am
the cure
you